-Performing "Crutch" from their new album,
"Things Are Great," give it up for Band of Horses!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Sticks tapping ]
♪♪
-♪ Not, not a long time ago I knew all the answers ♪
♪ I couldn't pace myself or raise my standards ♪
♪♪
♪ But one can hope, you need to know ♪
♪ And then the one stayed one, one stayed one ♪
♪ Forgotten where I was confusing it ♪
♪ With another that I saw ♪
♪ You wouldn't like nothing tonight ♪
♪ Beginning was quite disturbing ♪
♪ I got a crutch on you ♪
♪ Wishing there was something to do, do, do ♪
♪ Tablets in my pocket at the Easter soiree ♪
♪ Bouncing off the carpet in line for TSA ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
♪♪
♪ A lot of wasps on the walls, wasps on the walls ♪
♪ Bailing toilet water in lake full of moccasin ♪
♪ You're wrong, I'm right, no need to fight ♪
♪ The middle was dark and storming ♪
♪ You're on your own, I need to go ♪
♪ I got a crutch on you ♪
♪ Guess I got nothing to lose ♪
♪ Inebriated late afternoon ♪
♪ You were fading, now I'm holding on, too ♪
♪ I got a crutch on you ♪
♪ Wishin' there was something I could do ♪
♪ I sit around too long ♪
♪ Way too long ♪
♪ Thinking I should go, thinking I should go ♪
♪ I'm going, too ♪
♪♪
♪ Too ♪
♪ Got a crutch on you ♪
♪ Wishing there was something that I could do ♪
♪ Ooh-ooh-ooh ♪
♪ Got a crutch on you ♪
-♪ I've got a crutch on you ♪
-♪ Finally nothing left to do ♪
♪ Ooh-ooh-ooh ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]